adriana je vous prescris un produit
style aspirine normalement ça agit au
bout de vingt minutes pour 3 4 heures si
je suis vraiment convaincant il va agir
en cinq minutes toute la journée puis
suffisent très mauvais vous n'attendez
rien de moi à ce moment là non seulement
il n'a pas marché dans plus de rim à
l'estomac ça c'est l'effet nocebo
symbolique s'entend bien on s'en est
bien le fondateur du mouvement a déclaré
que seulement 10 à 15 minutes de yoga du
rire peuvent réduire le stress et aider
les gens à garder le moral dans les
moments difficiles le rire est le
meilleur des médicaments at il dit
surchauffe à l'assemblée nationale
depuis deux jours des heures de passes
d'armes entre la france insoumise qui
rejette toute la loi pouvoir d'achat et
le rassemblement national qui se montre
plus constructif en tout cas attention à
celui qu'ils n'iraient pas dans le sens
de la propagande en 2019 un chaman russe
annonçait vouloir exorciser vladimir
poutine de ses démons et bien elle a été
enfermée dans un hôpital psychiatrique
n'est pas l'une charlatans en fait
monsieur je vais chercher dix ans je
suis en province du sud du pays d'où ma
wii
en sortie
si je suivais l'eau mais monsieur series
et on coupe le gaz on coupe le pétrole à
tout le monde on coupe les sens on coupe
l'électricité tout de suite maintenant
il y aura plus de problème de pouvoir
d'achat ces phénomènes météo ne seront
bientôt plus exceptionnel dans le nifff
alors à défaut de s'habituer il va
falloir s'adapter
et oui je pense que notre philosophie
qui consiste à soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages ou qu'ils puissent
éclairer se loger se nourrir se déplacer
correctement est meilleure que celle qui
consiste à dire demain on est un tout et
vive la décroissance après deux heures
ils ont décidé d'ouvrir les portes d du
rer pour que les gens puissent sortir et
pour ceux qui le voulaient ils leur
proposer de regagner à pied le long des
rails dans l'obscurité la gare de
châtelet qui se trouvait à plus de 30
minutes à pied a nancy n'importe quoi et
puis dans les grandes gueules nous
accueillons un ancien ministre ancien
ministre des transports jean baptiste
djebbari bonjour monsieur jean baptiste
ravi d'être là enfin c'est sympa de
venir dans les grandes gueules avec
tiger woods par exemple alors pourrait
on pourrait vous appeler ma mavericks
djebbari je prends d'accord si vous avez
été pilote un tu as été puis d'autres
choses tutoyer dans les grandes gueules
mais le gouvernement a une hantise les
oppositions qui pourraient voter
ensemble et faire adopter des mesures
contre la majorité présidentielle par
exemple une baisse de la tva sur une
taxe carburant ou encore une taxe sur
les super-profits
tout peut arriver faut qu'on soit hyper
vigilant redoutent un proche de bruno
les maires de quel oeil et l'inspecteur
columbo voit-il
de sa femme
vous préférez que les salariés ne
touchent pas de prime parce que vous
considérez qu'il ne douche pas
suffisamment salaires mono préférant que
les salariés puissent dès maintenant dès
cet été j'ai des primes à cela pourrait
s'ajouter l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire
revaloriser cette année de 4 % pour un
montant maximum de 400 euros et puis
comme ça amandine et pourra dire est
peut-être s'acheter des un beau bel
agenda ou des choses comme ça ça te
plairait vous parmi vous qui sait ce que
c'est de vivre avec 1200 euros par mois
qui sait ce que c'est qui sait ce que
c'est
qui sait ce que c'est de ne pas remplir
son frigo qui sait ce que c'est de ne
prendre qu'un repas par mois par jour
pourquoi à nourrir ses enfants
des maisons de garde des
[Musique]
sceaux la france insoumise entendait
renommer la prime de partage de la
valeur vous savez c'est la prime dite
macron en prime enfumage c'est très
sérieux à ce que je dis ce n'est pas le
bon raffy sapé comme jamais vous lever
mais sa réponse lui rapporte 5000 euros
gène malaise voire mise en scène dénoncé
un internaute vous n'êtes pas là pour
faire avancer le voir d'axa vous êtes là
pour faire un petit jeu avec le roi
macro vous êtes les bouffons rouge du
roi macron nous voterons l'essentiel des
mesures que vous proposez
mais nulle et voteront en disant toute
la vérité aux français et en faisant des
propositions concrètes pour améliorer le
texte de nombreuses études ont ainsi
montré que le bleu fonctionnait mieux
pour l'insomnie le rose pour les
tranquillisants le jaune pour les
problèmes urinaires et fut un temps fut
un temps où la gauche notamment dans les
hautes france se battait pour amener le
plus possible de pouvoir d'achat y
compris quand c'était des petits pas
refusant les petits pas pour faire votre
cirque vous faites honte à la classe des
travailleurs et vous faites honte à
cette assemblée qui a besoin de rentrer
de l'argent français je décide de sortir
le grand jeu mais c'est vraiment le high
level ça va lui faire comprendre qu'elle
a une place importante dans la
considération mon nom de panique pour
les passagers avant que la ram ne puisse
finalement redémarrer et s'extirper de
ses paysages de la province de zamora
dans le nord-ouest de l'espagne et jouer
un bon cas d'absence pas simple c'est
difficile souvenez-vous jurisprudence
marion cotillard dans batman
sonner un peu demain à clotilde
on est impuissant on ne peut rien faire
c'était de beaux villages avec un
paysage agréable et vert maintenant tout
ce qu'on voit ce sont des cendres
[Musique]
l'apocalypse ne fait pas un projet
politique pour la nation française